foreign
comes from Linda in Colorado she says
this my husband changed positions within
his company and needs to return his
company work truck and we now need to
buy a quote new truck a lot of new
trucks and used trucks are within a few
thousand dollars of each other sometimes
you used ones are almost the same as new
I have heard you say many times not to
buy new because of the immediate
depreciation of driving it off but does
this weird Market SKU that advice
my husband also reminded me that you
said that if you have enough money you
should just buy what you want even
though we are debt free and have a 5
million dollar assets uh and cash I am
still kind of a penny pincher and want
to keep the truck at or under 30k what
advice can you give us regarding new or
used oh man I love this question you
know
I get it like I think sometimes you can
look at the car market and you can think
okay like I want to do everything the
Dave way and especially with them it
sounds like they're well into baby step
seven you know I think sometimes when
you're in that you just get used to that
that feeling of holding back and you
know putting aside but you know I think
that you guys have earned the right
Linda to go ahead and buy this truck
you've got five million in net worth and
and we teach here that if you're if your
net worth is over a million dollars you
have earned the right to purchase the
car that you would like to drive and not
only a used vehicle you could actually
purchase it outright now if that doesn't
feel right for you I think that's fine
but basically right now I'm just giving
you permission to go ahead and get the
car that or the truck in this case that
you're wanting to get now you gave him
permission to get the truck she didn't
want to yeah that's true she didn't want
to and they wanted it might not she
wanted us to tell him we can't buy a
truck when he's got five million dollars
dude buy whatever truck you want buy the
truck seriously that's ridiculous and
she wants to keep it under 30k I think
no no no no no you need to get a good
truck yeah let him go have a big truck
big expensive five million dollars I
mean seriously now that's you you drive
like no one else so later you can drive
like no one else yep and so that's the
thing and and you're in great shape has
nothing to do with the new market versus
the used Market I don't need to give you
a rationalization the only
rationalization for you buying a brand
new freaking truck with five million
dollars is you want it or in this case
he wants it so buy the man a truck
that's what you do that's right you do
this it's a small thing yeah it's just
it if you listen let's say he drives a
60 000 truck all right let's double her
thing
forgets to put insurance on it doesn't
set the parking brake it rolls off the
cliff right
so now instead of five million dollars
they have four million it's a fraction
nine hundred and forty thousand dollars
they're still rich
do it again tomorrow
[Applause]
the point is it doesn't matter that's
right that's when you know you can
afford it yep it doesn't matter
mathematically you know when you don't
do it is when you make fifty thousand
dollars a year and you buy a sixty
thousand dollar truck and you've still
got a student loan debt and three credit
cards and your sixty thousand dollar
truck turns into thirty thousand in
value in 13 seconds and then you scratch
your head and wonder why you can't fund
your kids college fund because you're
broke see that's stupid straight up yeah
because the new market and the youth
Market are close oh shut up you're bro
you don't need to buy a truck that's
what it you know so don't the
rationalization doesn't matter it's the
reasoning and the reasoning's got to do
with the ratios so you're exactly right
Jade lady you're sweet and you're kind
and you're Penny pitching ways is what
got you all here but you need to enjoy
the money too I'll tell you one other
thing you need to do you need to turn up
your generosity button about three
notches that's it crank it up a little
more and that helps you with your penny
pinching that's so good when you're when
you're giving more it also allows you to
enjoy the money more in personal
purchases as without feeling like you've
done something wrong absolutely because
then again you're playing that ratio
game exactly